the couple that yoga's together stays  together  hashtag perfect true romance ID  [Music]  [Applause]  congratulations oh my god  romantically hashtag la is that I'm  making a ton of new friends you should  totally follow me on Instagram that's  good  [Music]  suspicious dodging rocks maybe you're  confusing there was none of your insta  fam yes by far the coolest just  interesting person I've ever met  I love you so much you're amazing  my best friend Taylor's been helping me  for my creative side if you got lower  that would be better in the floor yeah  thanks is the best I need you to tell  everyone you're my boyfriend  what why are you acting like very good  like these people  [Music]  [Laughter]  [Music]  Nikki where's my phone your password to  your phone is my 15th birthday I'm not a  psychopath  hi home I just want to be her friend are  you actually insane  [Applause]  [Music]  Tupac's every day like this  [Music]  you